sous les pieds des sharks rhin repose
2000 ans d'histoire le service
d'archéologie de la ville un des plus
importants de france sensibilise les
échos liés au métier d'archéologue
c'est un kia qui repère les tranchées
qui doit laisser le pas de dinosaures à
chartres mais les vestiges d'un riche
passé stockées sur cette ancienne base
militaire et des des enquêteurs on est
presque des policiers du passé ont fait
on enquête et le moindre indice nous
permet de nous permet un petit peu de
retracer l'histoire de ce qu'ils ont
vécu sur le site construit sauvegarde
par les archives pour la photographie
car la topographie
nous on est les derniers témoins souvent
de deux sites qui on est appelé à
disparaître totalement donc on est un
peu les gardiens de la mémoire en fait
donc là on voit bien sûr le sur le plan
du 15e le bureau d'octroi devant la
devant la barbacane la barbacane au
moyen-âge protéger l'entrée de chartres
la ville impose et l'octroi une taxe sur
les marchandises venues de la campagne
comme le blé donc quand on entrait dans
la ville beau qu'on pouvait entrer par
la porte guillaume où il y avait un
bureau d'octroi donc payer ont payé un
droit d'entrée ont mesuré la quantité de
grains qu'ont apporté en ville dans ces
petites mesures à grains et aulas on a
bien le bec pour après reverser le grain
dans le sac en fait à la fin de la
guerre la tour guillaume a été saboté à
l'explosif par les allemands en fuite
un jour elle sera reconstruite car
chaque pierre d'origine et numérotées et
son emplacement archives et on pensait
qu'ils avaient plus rien que l'implosion
de la porte guillaume et l'occupation
pendant la guerre avait tout détruit
en fait non on
2 millions d'occupation depuis le
premier siècle jusqu'à jusqu'au 21e
siècle en fait c'est pour ça c'est
exceptionnel engine c'est assez
exceptionnel a quand même on a tout les
céramiques
on a tous les restes d'animaux qui ont
été soit consommée soit
sur place nous verrons demain avec une
archéozoologue l'utilité des ossements
et pourquoi ceux des lièvres sont
synonymes de plaine